let's say you need a car to go off-road
let's also say that you need to drive
really really fast like 187 miles an
hour fast and you want to do both with
style to spare let's also say that you
have 230 thousand dollars to spend on an
SUV then the Ben taga Bentley's first
foray into sport utility might be just
the vehicle the been tiger is the
forerunner of a new slate of ultra luxe
SUVs from Lamborghini Aston Martin and
Rolls Royce inside their assumption
seats state of the art navigation tools
and even night-vision assist exactly the
sort of luxury one would expect from the
Bentley behind the wings on the grill is
a six litre 12 cylinder engine that
cranks out a dust churning 600
horsepower the bent a go will snap your
head back into those other seats with a
0 to 60 times just four seconds now it
won't crawl over in the same rock
gardens but it is as capable as any
other high-end SUV but with all the mud
hosed off the Ben Tagish should slide
right in beside the McLaren's and the
Ferrari is down at the Polo Club game on
rolls Heston in Lambo
game on